and often in film festivals they'll tell
you like the ticket to buy at the film
festival is the short compilations
because that's where the really most
exciting filmmaking is happening
what is the short film what is the short
film is a really good question because a
short film can be anything but I think
what defines a short film obviously is
the links it's a short film and there's
actually a few organizations that do
have like a definite defined length of
what how long a short film should be
for example like if you want to be uh
considered for an Academy Award the
academy says a short film is I believe
the academy is 40 minutes or less for
narrative documentary sometimes has
different lengths for their films quite
often for film festivals in the
application they'll say specifically how
long the short film can be disqualifies
for short film usually it's like 50
minutes or less although personally I
think if you're making like a 50 minute
long short film that's a too long of a
short film short films should be short
in my opinion
do you know what percentage actually
it's way past a half hour I mean it
isn't generally it's 15 minutes or under
well a lot of people because they see
short films that are longer they think
that's how long a short film should be
so they've seen student films that you
know the university requires the film to
be a certain length because it's a
learning experience right so you want to
do a longer film so you get the full
experience of making something you know
you're not making something on half a
day and it's 30 seconds long or
something like that so when people are
used to seeing these kind of longer
short films they think oh that's what
makes a good short film a short film
should be 20 minutes long or 30 minutes
long or they worry people won't take
them seriously if their film is not that
long but truthfully because I've seen a
ton of films on the festival circuit I
feel like if you're beyond 12 minutes
you're just too long and quite often for
like dramatic films 12 minutes is like a
nice sweet spot like aim for 12 minutes
or less I'm always a big fan of or less
but if it's a comedy short or a short
you expect to have be on the internet
nobody's going to be watching a
12-minute short on the internet you know
at the internet we have no attention and
we want to be short short short and
comedies you know as with features if
you're too long you outstay your welcome
you should be short fast and funny
has it changed as as different uh social
media platforms have given us more short
content well also when you say what
defines a short film you know things
that people are making for on social
media are shorts right I wouldn't
necessarily call them films per se but
they're short pieces of content so you
know like when Tic Tac Tick Tock started
it was extremely short teeny teeny teeny
is what it was supposed to be and there
used to be a service called Vine and
that was like six seconds long and that
I would consider those shorts not
necessarily films but short pieces of
content so it is amazing how much you
can tell in a short short time period of
time but even Tick Tock realized they
had to start giving people more time you
know that it's really hard to do such to
actually do some kind of Storytelling in
a very very very very like you know one
minute or less time frame
having said that I've seen great short
films that are a minute or less
what draws you to the short film genre
I'm kind of unique in the sense that I
started out the first thing I ever
produced was a feature and then I
started producing short films and people
always say don't you want to go back to
features and I love shorts it's like
features features are hard short films
are fun fast and easy to do and that's
where I think the most exciting
storytelling is and often in film
festivals they'll tell you like the
ticket to buy at the film festival is
the short compilations because that's
where the really most exciting
filmmaking is happening unique voices
are happening unique things that you can
do with cameras and fun you know
off-the-wall things all happen in short
films first because we can it's a format
to experiment in to take chances in to
do crazy things and you don't have that
same pressure of having to do like a 90
minute storyline with three acts and
characters who have to develop and all
the things that you know you have to
make happen for a feature with the short
film you can even take like a small
smallest idea and do it great and well
and crazy and unexpected and surprising
and so that's what I love so much about
short films every year there are so many
made and every year there are so many
that are just amazing that you've never
seen anything like that before they're
funny they're surprising they're
touching they're moving and so many
feature films I'm sure everybody
watching this has had that experience
that you pay your money to go see in the
theater and you feel very disappointed
afterwards you're like it's the same old
same old or oh I was expecting it to be
so much better often because the trailer
kind of sold you on how great it was
going to be because the trailer is
showing you all the best moments but the
resulting feature is long and not great
where short films rarely disappoint
has there been a Resurgence in shorts or
short filmmaking has never really gone
away well the thing about short
filmmaking is uh you know it's always
been around right when actually when
when filmmaking started it was short
films there was one reelers right that
those were the silent films that people
could make and the birth of films was
shorts
um and then they graduated related to
more and more reels that became a
full-length feature so short filming is
always always been there and students
make shorts all the time so in that
sense it's always been there as well but
what has made it very Democratic
what has made it easy and accessible and
Universal to everybody is now that you
know we have something in our pockets
that are cameras that we can shoot films
on and that has never been the case
before so every single person
practically has the ability to shoot
something and that's a miracle now
whether you're actually a Storyteller
that's something completely different
but you actually can
put your camera up film something put a
title on it put it out on YouTube put it
out on social media and you've made a
short film so in that sense there's more
short films being made than ever and we
often use the statistics from the
Sundance Film Festival because they're
very uh out with you know public with
their numbers and every year they say
this many short films have been
submitted to the Sundance Film Festival
and it has grown exponentially when I
was making short films very small amount
because people were still shooting on
film and then again you know we can
shoot digitally and now we can shoot on
so many different formats but so many
people are making short films so last
year the people that applied to this
year's Sundance Film Festival last year
they were obviously making their films
during the pandemic but still over ten
thousand people made short films and
submitted to Sundance so you can see
that's a lot and that's of course only
people who submitted to Sundance but
that's a lot of people making short
films how many types of short films are
there short films that can incorporate
anything so when you say types it's like
what does that mean exactly does that
mean like live action animation
documentary those are kind of or mixed
media
um or those are buckets that you can say
and that's kind of what way um people
classify short films like for example
the academy when they do their short
films Awards it is live action animation
documentary but when you say short films
does it mean something like a narrative
short that has done a traditional short
filmmaking way is it something that is
like a parody is it something that is
you know an Adaptive short story that
has turned into a short there's so many
different kinds of shorts within those
buckets and that's again what I love
about short films is like basically
anybody can say something what they've
made is a short
nobody's going to stop you because
there's no like official board that says
this is a short this is a short you
could decide I'm going to make something
I'm deciding it's a short and here it is
it's out in the world so you know for
Sundance 10 000 people submitted short
films this last year for consideration
for the film festival
what were those 10 000 short films how
do you define what they were you know
obviously the programmers watched ten
thousand and they could answer more
accurately what they saw amongst those
different things but sometimes it is
literally people who have no clue what
they're doing and they just say oh I've
made a short film because I ran you know
a push record on my camera and I pushed
stopped and that's what it is and they
submit it and again I'm not saying that
is not a short film
um but it might not be something that's
worth our while watching
and then there's the definition of a
vlog which could have typically the
length of a short but there is that
there's it's like someone speaking to
the camera as if they're like zooming
with you right so what is that a short
film per se you know but what if it was
with an actor who was that was written
and it was something that had a definite
beginning middle and end so it wasn't a
legitimate Vlog but it was a story that
was told in the format of a vlog
and it has a title that I would consider
that a short film but a actual real Vlog
I would not consider a short film in the
same way you would say like is a news
broadcast a short film however like I
would used to always say this bruter
film from the Kennedy assassination
could that be a documentary short that
like everybody had seen around the world
is that a short I don't know maybe it's
just a news feature what's the
difference between a two to four minute
short and a 20 minute short well the
difference between a two minute short
and 20 minutes short obviously is
running time but it doesn't necessarily
mean that a two minute short isn't as
good as a 20 minute short or that a 20
minute short should be taken more
seriously than a two-minute short
because I've seen amazing films that
were two minutes long and I've seen
amazing films that were 20 minutes long
I've also seen films that are 20 minutes
long that should not have been 20
minutes long and one of the main
criticism of anyone who deals with short
films professionally like maybe they're
a TV programmer or they're a program for
for a festival is that short films are
too long the problem is many people
write and direct and edit and produce
the short film themselves so they're
like a one-man band and they've done
everything which is great because it's a
terrific learning experience but they're
often not good editors or because they
also wrote it and shot it that they
can't tell what they need to take out or
not and with a short film concise
concise edit down you know we we paid
attention to every single moment in a
short film because every single moment
is important so quite often that 20
minute long film has really only enough
story for 12 minutes per se but the
filmmaker can't see because they're too
close to it and they've touched every
single part of it what can be taken out
to make it shorter so you know I
personally when I see a 20 minute long
film I'm watching it going oh this
should have been shut down this should
have been cut down that's too much
there's there I also have a thing called
feature film pacing and that's because
we've grown up watching feature films
and television and that's so naturally
that's our pacing when we watch things
we expect them to go in that space well
film has 90 minutes or a TV show that
has 42 minutes has a lot of time to set
up a lot of information and do a lot of
things where short film doesn't have all
that time and a short film you should be
paying attention to every single moment
so quite often a 20-minute long film has
feature film pacing where they'll like
spend way too much time at the beginning
with like a long credit opening sequence
that for feature you have to do
contractually but for short nobody wants
to watch that we don't need to we don't
want to we want to get right into the
story I used to have a friend that we'd
go to festivals together and he'd be
like every short film starts with
somebody walking somewhere in a short
film no you're already there and then
we'd watch and we'd be like sure enough
somebody's walking somewhere no in a
feature sure you can walk somewhere you
can stop at the store you can chat with
friends and then you'll get to where you
want to go but in a short film you are
already there and we're already going
every single moment counts in a short
film
so in the similarity of let's say a
novel a novella and a short story
there's rules that apply to each each
length of a manuscript exactly so like a
short film a short story there's a
certain style that goes for a short
story and we know when we're reading it
it's only going to go a certain amount
of pages and we know it's going to have
an ending that's going to come up kind
of quickly so we're interested in where
where that ending is going to come and
it was very rare that a short story can
be expanded to being a novella or even a
like novel nobody reads the short and
goes you know they really have a novel
here maybe you should expand it
sometimes it happens but it's rare that
it does so for a short film it has its
own style and it has its own thing that
we're expecting from it and then yeah
maybe Novella would be those 50-minute
shorts which usually isn't documentary
you know that it's more like a TV
episode that just happens to be a
documentary and we're used to that too
from you know from watching TV
documentaries that are that long but
it's totally acceptable to have 70
minute doc you know maybe you have a
long story you need to convey but not
enough to make it full 90 minutes and
cruel it would have been cool to cut
that story down to half an hour or 20
minutes it has to be 50 minutes or 40
minutes I think documentaries a whole
another kettle of fish but again with
short films anything goes you can do
whatever you want and if you come up
with a story that only works in 10
minutes then do it in 10 minutes if you
come up a story that you have to take 40
minutes to do and that truly is as long
as it needs to be then go for it
or maybe it really is a feature and
maybe that 10 minutes you've made is to
kind of hook people into realizing that
there's actually a feature in here so
there's quite a lot of short films that
are that they're kind of like proof of
concept or a little teaser of what the
feature could be
right and this is just a side note but I
think the LA Times is now done in this
new short docs that they have yes New
York Times has did it first uh and those
are very very popular and then obviously
just times it's not doing too but you
know what anybody who wants to give
credit to short films and show short
films more power to them uh because you
know that's kind of the hardest thing is
to get people to see your film so if
there's some kind of organization like a
film festival or a imprint like the New
York Times opdocs or the LA time stocks
that's just so fabulous they're putting
them out there they're getting a
promotion because truthfully nowadays
the easiest thing is to make a film this
is for shorts and for features the
hardest thing is to get distribution and
to get people to watch your film